Test and Test
[music]
and a new Test and Test
hello ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the
press conference of the 7 Berlin science
week
also for everyone who is
going online hello and thank you for being
there and also in English because we
international guests also online have
dated everybody thanks for Beemer
does the day and welcome to the seven to
the press conference of the seven
science week
over the course of the next hour
our podium guests will guide you through
selected topics of the balance science
path and afterwards
the one  short question and
answer session with questions from the audience both
here physically and digitally
our panel guests are Ulrike Gotha
Senator for Science Health
Care and Equality of Berlin
Jürgen lieneck coordinator barking
science week falling was Foundation
Christoph marxis President of the
Berlin-Brandenburg Academy of
Sciences
Anna Schindler  director
Urban development of the city of Zurich via
live switch from Zurich
Julia von Blumenthal, President of the
Humboldt University in Berlin and
Cecile Oliveira, also via live switch,
head of the research group on
democratic governance for
ocapolitical transformation at the
ias-potsdam,
our press conference will be broadcast
live, so all guests and
press representatives the  If you are online, you
are welcome to submit your question in the
live chat.
The live transmission is also accompanied by
English subtitles
so that our guests from international
media can also take part. As
part of the derberland science week, there
has also been a
fellowship program for international
journalists for several years  and we are
very pleased that the 2022 group
can also be there today
at this point I would also like to say
thank you to the Berlin-
Brandenburg Academy of
Sciences and Humanities from a whole balance science fiction team  that
we can hold our press conference today at
your beautiful premises
since 2016, the Berlin science week has become
a place where people from
science, business, politics, culture
and society come together
under the motto of to know
, the Balance science week brings together
international organizations from all over
world to
present excellent science, to initiate and promote debate on the greatest
challenges of our time
and to
find new interactive ways to make
science, research and innovation
tangible for everyone.
The festival program includes a number
of different formats of
panel discussions, talks, science
slams and live streams
Exhibitions and film screenings for
everyone There is something
to learn more about our program and for
more details about the Science we can
click on our home page and
tables science week.com
global challenges such as the neither
de  r Ukraine Pandemic or
climate crisis put the important role
of science in the center and of
course one
has an influence on the
program of the Berlin science week and
we see that in many topics that are represented
this year whether climate crisis
or food crisis developments
in AI  Research material research
climate research and many others
the long tradition and
innovation potential of the
science location Berlin-Brandenburg
make this region an important
player and such an exciting place for
further debates and discussions on the
subject of
science  on November 1
with a series of exciting
events some of which we will
also hear again today, for
example a panel discussion in the
Berlin Brandenburg Academy to go to the
first part in Poland or an
exhibition research in
science and meet
on the 4 and  On November 5, the two campus days will take place as usual,
and for the first time we are
very pleased that the Humboldt University is a
partner of the campus
with the focus on
paradame shift cocreationable now
the two campus days are a place where
Knowledge-hungry and knowledge-interested
and researchers
from many different international
organizations come together to discuss
solutions for the future and
sustainability and all topics related
to the climate crisis and planetary
health
Like last year, the program is also divided into eleven
different topics from
medicine and planetary health
to technological innovations, open
science and collaboration and many
others,
and then highlights on campus are
other events such as
collaborative workshops with one
of Berlin Universi projects  ty alone
there is also an exciting
reading on the subject of AI and creativity and
also a
panel discussion on water as the
elixir of life in biodiversity and the
climate crisis, which Johannes
vogel-detector from the Museum of
Natural History is also taking part in, as is the
Swiss ambassador and many other
actors and scientists  from Berlin
and Zurich
Organization of the Balance science week
this year are, among others, the
Federal Ministry of Education and
Research futurium Charité Berlin
University alone
Leopoldina Center science Media Center
and many many others and at this
point I would like to hand over the floor to our
first speaker Mrs
Bids Senator for Science, please,
yes, thank you
very much, ladies and gentlemen,
Pandemic, war, climate crisis, how important is
scientific progress, how
important is research, how important is
knowledge that, especially when it
comes to overcoming multiple crises,
we have already had that in the last few years  d three
years ago during the corona crisis
but we are
actually experiencing this in a
practical course every day in the
times in which we live without
science without research without
progress we could neither
recognize nor solve crises in the
corona pandemic became us  very clear how
much we depend on
understanding
what research does and how it can help
, no matter how complex the results, the
research science may be, it
must be explainable and it must
remain accessible as Berlin's
Senator for Science, I am very grateful that our
scientific institutions here in
Berlin with its diversity and
internationality is of course not sitting in the
elfenbleimturm and doing research,
but is there for the citizens to
be experienced are to be approached
and that is what the Berlin University
Alliance and the br50 network of
non-university
research institutions have taken up the cause of
, but above all  em succeeds in doing this
in an outstanding way at the Berlin
science week
there it is precisely about getting science
and society to
talk to each other this year
it is mainly about
a question that I and I say that because
I am also an ecologist from the background
So I am an environmental scientist who
is particularly close to my heart what can
a more sustainable world look like and what
can research and science
contribute to it we all experienced
devastating
heat waves and droughts in Germany
and Europe this spring and summer, and even if we
are all worried now
we have to be aware of a cold winter
this October is
already too warm again
than it has been for decades
we are experiencing the crisis like we are now or as
expected many years ago we are
now experiencing how the climate crisis is affecting us
the health impairment
for older people  people for children and
other vulnera  ble groups are fatal,
not to mention the social,
ecological and economic consequences that
affect everyone here in Europe
worldwide right now,
science is in demand to find new approaches and
answers and to set impulses for
sustainable development and to
achieve the Sustainable Development
Goals  of the United Nations for a
socio-economic and ecologically
sustainable development,
forward-looking contributions from almost
all research disciplines will be
necessary in Berlin,
numerous scientific institutions
and researchers are already working on the
transdisciplinary topic of sustainability
with the coalition agreement, this government has set itself
the goal of the
small change center  to set up a
leading international center for climate research
together, also and in cooperation with
Brandenburg, the center
should leverage the existing excellent
research skills in Berlin and
Brandenburg  bring together what holds
our society together how
does social cohesion come about with its
Grand Challenge Initiative social
creation, the Berlin University
Alliance the excellence network of the three
Berlin universities and the Charité is looking for
answers to these social
questions of sustainability
Scientific institutions contribute to sustainable development not
only through their scientific
results
as essential elements
of the science system as employers
and as publicly partially or fully
funded organizations, they
also have the social mandate to deal
with their responsibility towards the environment,
society and
employees in their own research
and operational processes
that the Berlin science week deals with
dealing with these and numerous other topics makes me look forward
to the conference with great excitement and anticipation
it is really a blessing for Berlin  n
that so many people with so much
commitment and such an internationally
known event like
designsweg falling walls der to know
could not be said better that
almost everything that
is intended and wanted here at the
Science week comes together  the
scientific community no one can
compare to the
importance that the re:publica conference has
for the internet community
I would like
to express my sincere
thanks to the organizers and everyone involved, and in particular to Jürgen
Linnig, who came up with this idea of ​​coming
together  has continued for many, many
years and with the
falling wall team and the science
week team is always setting new accents
and giving an unbelievable amount of energy to this
project.
Walls have to come down if we all
want to make progress that still
applies and that applies all the more  in times like
these this applies to science
Just as
I am looking forward to politics in this sense, I am looking forward to the
new ideas that will come up and be
discussed this year on the subject of sustainability and hopefully the international guests who have gathered will turn many things that are
taken for granted upside down
and this is something that society needs to change again and
again  moving forward, especially
this approach in thinking, is essentially
sustainable thank you thank you so
much Ms gothek please
[applause]
good morning
, ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to
our press conference for the Berlin
Science Week, I am very pleased, Madam
Senators, that you are here today,
thank you very much,
President  markis, my President of the
Academy Christoph, thank you very much for the
hospitality here today
in the einstein hall, many
thanks to Julia von Blumenthal, the
Humboldt University is
particularly
present this year, we are very happy about that, also in
connection with the
science campus and I g  Say hello to
the colleague from the iasf in
Potsdam and the colleague from Zurich
I am very happy because many years ago I was a
young professor at the
ETH but that was a long time ago but there
is still a great
bond
with Switzerland and especially with
City of Zurich, thank you very much for the people of
Zurich being premium partners this year, as the
saying goes. Maybe I can
try to make it clear again briefly
how this Berlin science week
actually developed, what is behind it
, I think that's it  It's
always important to keep in mind
what we actually want to achieve, what
we want to achieve is
gone with the Bellen science
and with the falling walls science
summit, to create a place where
everyone in the world meets once a year for the
topic  Science research and
innovation are burning and believe that with this we can
solve the problems of the future of
our society and also
not only but
certainly not without them, and if we in the heart of
Europe USA on the one hand
Asia and the Pacific on the other hand
with China
in the heart of Europe have the
opportunity to make this topic of science,
research and innovation strong
, like I do  I still find
falling walls under this good name
in Berlin and then on November 9th, the day
when
a turning point took place in 1989
and we are now in the process of building
walls again rather than
letting walls fall, so I think that's a
big one  Opportunity for not only the state of
Berlin, so Ms. grote we are
also very grateful for the support
that the state of Berlin has
given us again this year over the years, because
Berlin knows you have made it
clear how important
science is for
the city  and the state of Berlin is
but in the end it only works together
it only works if the other
institutions here agree to the R  egion and the
city are behind it if the big
scientific organizations
in Germany are behind it the
universities foundation companies that
applies to Europe that's why we are so
happy that Zurich is present here this
year in an
exemplary way and
ultimately it's international we can
create a place here similar to  It's where
it is for the world of business or
Munich for security politicians, where
everyone who is passionate about science, research and
innovation
comes together. That's the goal,
so the core was this falling worlds
conference, but even if it's
great for two days, someone really comes
from San Francisco Tokyo or
Sydney and the idea of ​​the Berlin science
week was
around it to enable
organizations foundation
universities companies worldwide
to have their own
event under their own name
here in Berlin so
that someone from San Francisco says okay
so f  I wouldn't
have come for two days but there's
so much going on in Berlin for a week now I can
meet so many interesting people here where I
would otherwise have to call around 100 times I ca
n't even get them on the line
I can get there and
maybe combine that with a  I was
planning a visit to you in Europe or even in
Germany, that's the idea and I
think we've made progress step by step, I
think we're on the right track, but
as I said, it's only possible together and
I think
Ms. Senators, you've got that
also from this point of view,
sustainability has just been discussed
there are so many great challenges
for science and research
that can offer solutions
this is the place where you can discuss
them maybe a few numbers and then
I'll be done we have
200 events this year  over 400
speakers distributed over the Böllen
science week
there is of course always d
This uncertainty, what will Ms. Gude
we Spaniards about, I'll say the
curve situation, what will be in mid-
November or early November,
nobody really knows, we
're preparing for the face-to-face meeting, of course,
but
we're also preparing for the fact that you'll
just have to wear a mask  and if necessary tests
and so on have to work that is of
course also noticeable at the Balance
science week we have
more face-to-face events this time than
last year but still a
series of digital or
hybrid events simply because many
are still unsure I'm
really going
through there now  world history and so
on and so forth we all hope that
this will be different at some point
, we think it's better this year
than last year
and the encouragement we have
from the participating organizations
is
wonderful, it's also international me  I
don't want to focus so much on individual
topics now  we always try to take
up current topics when
you leaf through the program you will
see how diverse the offer
is again I also find the supplement if I
may say so the
representatives of the
Tagesspiegel thank you
very much from the tagesspiegelbild again very successfully
because  You can see how
diverse the contributions are that will take place in the course of
this week. I
just want to highlight two or three topics because I'm a physicist
. If you forgive me,
there will be an
event on the topic of quantum computing,
including with the IBM
research laboratory  Rüschlikon Zurich
where this topic is being discussed again even after the
Nobel Prizes that have now been awarded,
it is really
international there will be a
symposium on the subject of the James Web Telescope the
first pictures are now there fantastic
new insights into what makes up the universe, so to speak, that
's all  I
say premium  ere and that’s where the heart of
a physicist beats
faster I have to say and it will be the same for
other disciplines too so at this
point I would like to thank everyone
again for their participation the Museum of Natural History is doing the campus again for two days
the Humboldt University is standing  a
wonderful lecture hall
nearby and is actively involved we also
have events here in the
bbrw Christoph so a big
contribution here on site I am very happy and I would also like to
thank the Berlin science
week team, namely Christine Brummer
and her colleagues very much  Thank you very much again
for the good preparation and
Alena for the press work in this
sense. I am looking
forward to this year's Berlin
Science Trail
a very warm
welcome my s  Dear ladies
and gentlemen, and of course also my
senator Ms. Gothe, my president
Julia von Blumenthal as a
Humboldt professor and Jürgen,
I can say that to my ex-president, because
I came to Berlin, maybe you can say that
briefly at a press conference like this  because there was
someone sitting in the office of the President of the Humboldt University with a
piece of paper in his hand and the
opening question of the conversation was what
do you want, we were still per you
what do you want and that is in a
certain sense also representative
of Berlin science  week to the point
clearly precise not a lot of frills
but not too complex and I,
as President of the
Berlin-Brandenburg Academy, stand for the
fact that one of the characteristics that characterizes
Berlin is how well we work together in the very
different
directions the universities the
Academy of Sciences as a
special  great humanities
research  institution that also provides
social and political advice
and I haven’t mentioned it yet from
Zurich and from Potsdam also the
Berlin-Brandenburg science region
and Jürgen Lünek said it and
this nature lady the many guests we
have I’m doing the following now that I
like  that Jürgen Lünek did
highlight three events so that
you can see what the profile of our
academy is that we are incorporating
into this wonderful week together with others
and you mentioned the first
right at the beginning it
might be strange that we were on the
first day of the Berlin  science week talk about
the division of Poland
when you stand in Vilnius and see
that there are big attacks in Vilnius, the capital of Lithuania
, that the Warsaw
Ministry is
financing restoration measures in Vilnius and when you are currently,
until recently, that was still possible,
the Berlin-Brandenburg Academy
supports you  hospital in  Lemberg
in levoff in levif so if you go to the
Ukraine then you will notice and
we have
learned that since the dreadful February 24 at the latest. You
do not understand the conflict and you
cannot adequately do what our
task is at the moment if you do not
know the history  So with a
presenteeism that only
refers to what is happening at the moment
, you also work under complex, so
the Berlin science-weg is also about
the Ukraine and it's about the
history of this conflict and for
everyone who has the feeling we know too
little  we failed to
inform ourselves a first offer among
many others is on November 1st the
opportunity to find out about the
history of how everything is connected
point out that the
BBAW not only
makes and publishes historical research  happily
join others in the böllenz Science week
we also have many partners from Poland
from institutions in Germany who are
doing research with Poland who are connected at this
point and Julia von
Blumenthal also stands for a university
that has been involved with and very
intensively for a long time  Poland dealt with before
you came here to Berlin is a
second topic that the BBAW deals with,
we not only do research in the field of
digital humanities but also
deal with fundamental questions of
digitization and digitality open
research data this is a small
conference that we are holding as part of this
böllenz  science week
and which is about how we make the
ideal of justice and science
accessible to everyone
keep open data really fair
current and central  Topic that
we will also deal with, how
do justice,
research standards and affordability come
together, and finally I
wanted to point out that on
November 9th, at the end of the whole story, so to speak,
we were giving a
lecture at the Academy with the deeply
controversial topic, how is it with the
Discourse control in Germany you
know there are people who stand
up and say that freedom in our
country is threatened and others write
that on Twitter so that everyone can
read it and you get the impression
that freedom can't really be threatened
if you say that  Twitter
can write widely and an academy does
n't want to yell along on one side or the other but want to bring
research data into this controversy
, so Berlin's Heinz way
is always up to date but it's
scientifically up-to-date we do
n't yell at one point but
provide the appropriate information
and there  ten as I said at the beginning
like Jürgen lynek on a piece of paper
that was clear and direct I wasn't at all prepared at the time
what I was
supposed to answer and he then
said yes, now be clear about this
point and about this point and then
the note is full and I was able to leave the office
and came to Berlin
so you should do the same
thank you very much [applause] thank you very much Mr. Maxis thank you very
much and we have our first
live counter at the Schindler from
Zurich please Mrs. schindler
yes  Thank you very much, ladies and
gentlemen, I hope you can hear me. I am
very happy that from a distance
I can bring you closer to the cooperation
between Zurich and Berlin and in Berlin
and I
am also very happy that we will soon be
three  I hope there will be weeks in Berlin
with lots of physical
events Zurich with Berlin is
the sixth edition of a global
series of events  he in Zurich connects with
inspiring metropolises of the
world we are doing a festival and
with this festival we are creating a small
festival and the Canton of
Zurich and Zurich Tourism
together with the important Zurich
universities create an international
platform for the
areas of science, innovation and
culture,
Berlin science  -weg is also
a global networking platform
for science and in this function
an absolutely ideal partner for our
exchange
format
should already
happen in 2020 but we
all know it Corona came and because
our festival is
also heavily based on physical exchange
we have decided
to postpone it twice now and hope that we can
really come now we want 20
events  Altungen are presenting exciting
events from
14 to 8 November, which means we
are between the ETH
University of Zurich University of
Applied Sciences and the
Zurich University of the Arts and they are
presenting current research and projects on the topic of
sustainability.
I would like to name just a few
key topics
First of all, the ETH Zurich and the Psyche
University of the Arts will
jointly
deal with the relationship between technology and the
topics of art, urban development and
human
creativity in several events  Saturday, November 5th and
in an event on
sustainability in the fashion industry, the
12 University of Applied
Sciences will, in addition to
events, address sustainable
nutrition and present
solutions, but also the
klimawi  economy and the digitization
of the public sector and finally
I would like to draw your attention to the
Zurich Berlin event
together for sustainable development
on November 5th. It is a
joint discussion round of all
partners from Zurich
in close cooperation with local
organizations from Berlin  really
a bridge between Zurich and
Berlin Zurich will also have a special
presence I must in natural history
Berlin science like campus from 4 and 5
November the Zurich universities
will use
the entrance hall of the museum the
dinosaur hall with exhibitions on the
subject of sustainability in the areas during these two campus days
But building and nutrition we will also show
a simulation of the Aletsch Glacier
for the various
climate change scenarios or an
interactive exhibition on the
conditions of raw material extraction
for mobile technology
visit our website  You can of
course find Berlin with
dort.org and I would
also like to invite you, I said, the festival also
revolves around culture. We would like to
invite you to our cultural program,
organize two concert evenings with the
artists
Keime dioprandal and some more on 4
November in the
urban Spray and on November 5th in the
Maria Antoinette I would be very
happy to see you all there and
yes thank you very much for your interest
thank you very much Anna Schindler Director of
Urban Development City of Zurich
thank you and next Julia von
Blumenthal please
yes dear Ms. Gothe dear  Mr markschis,
dear Mr Lünnek,
ladies and gentlemen, it is really
a great pleasure for me that I
still have the opportunity to stand
here for the Humboldt University in my first month
in office. We are an official cooperation partner for the first time,
but we
were involved  individual events, of
course, from the start because the
International networking of
science is understandable for a university
for the Humboldt University
and also reaching out
into society is one of our
important goals that we pursue for ourselves and of
course also in the Berlin University
Alliance
and under the keyword open Humboldt
is us  made it my task to make science accessible and accessible to society in
special places and with special
partners
and to
bring it closer to it and so
they also allow me to throw a few spotlights
that I think say a lot about
what special places and special
partners are for us is the first thing  an
event in the Humboldt Labor
almost within sight of here that we are
also organizing in cooperation with our
european
university alliance Circle you you
could say the
european counterpart to the Berlin
University Airlines that is
the
possibility under the title Conversation of the Trees  I think
we were able to find out how important the resilience of forests is to the scientist Marcel Robby
in Berlin-
Brandenburg last summer and also in the
years before and
to deal more closely with
what highly complex systems
forests are like  the living beings involved in them
flows of substances energy-
then something completely different, perhaps much more
abstract lünek has already mentioned
quantum physics, which we at
Humboldt University also address in a very
special way, namely
in cooperation with Roman Lipski
under the heading quantum physics
meets artistic practice you have an
opportunity to approach this topic in an artistic way
on November 4th in the studio
of Roman Lipski so also a
special place where you would
not normally meet science
I think this is a
great chance to get one like that
to approach an abstract topic,
then on Saturday, November 5th, you can
spend a whole day focusing on the topic of
language, how do we learn language
from childhood to
adulthood, from my
point of view this is also a topic related to our
current questions of diversity and
understanding in society  connected to
a high degree and what it
is good to be able to learn more about you can
go into a language acquisition laboratory here
and really see how
language acquisition takes place in experiments
for children for adults and in
lectures and here it is also important
what this nature already has
mentioned that we are doing this as a
Berlin-Brandenburg cooperation
because of my professional background,
which hermagisches also pointed out,
this
Berlin-Brandenburg
scientific landscape is really close to my
heart and I am very happy
that this event is a
cooperation with the
university spotsdam and in the
leibniz center  For general
linguistics,
a last brief spotlight on Ms.
Gotha has already
alluded to it and Mr. Marx also mentioned
February 24, 2022, the day on which the
ongoing Russian war against
Ukraine reached such a level
that we also took note of
it here  If I
may put it a bit bluntly, the Russian letter of
attack on Ukraine also
has direct effects on
our
way of life and Harald Grete will
speak about the war of aggression on
Ukraine and its implications for
national and international agricultural and
food policy in a classic
important lecture in  our format of the
kosmos-reading and I am very happy that in
Mr. Grete we
were able to win someone who takes up this topic that is so
urgent for us
I am very much looking forward to these
events I hope
that there will be great interest I hope that
we will actually be present  t  can
meet and find direct
exchange so that science can show
what great contribution we can make to
perhaps solving our problems in
the world, but also to the
question of what questions we
actually want to ask, because that's where I
always see our role as science
Above all,
ask the questions and Ms. Gothe nod, as a
senator, politicians often
have to actually decide the answers
to which we offer you the
knowledge so that you can make wise decisions
,
thank you, thank you, Hille von Blumenthal
and our last speaker, Cecilia
Oliveira, leader  the research group
democratic governance for
ecopolitical transformation an
institute for transformative
sustainability research Potsdam
see you thank you Action
me to dispress conference six not being
person with you today from here
I have to contributions to the science
week that like to share with you when
the first days d  ocumentary
moviejaco Amazon of 1 the second it's an
evening of storytelling book
contributions explore how the climate
the crisis require as to Riff think our
relationship to nature
[music]
activities in the in the under the
science of like you and the Wember first
also 7 clock you have the searches and
the story Collider we're for the
personal takes of how they are research
really change is them and how they can
drink also personal takes and the
personalities to estorytelling and this
power of the storytelling for research
and science  thank you very much
[applause]
thank you very much cecila Oliveira from iss
Potsdam
we're done with our wheels so far
and now we're going
to our Q&A session if anyone from
the audience has
any questions heronsheimer has a question and he's about to
get a mic
thanks my first  Question then goes to Mr.
müllnik, if you can please
clarify again,
the path you are on has you
shown where e  s is the
target, but in my opinion you have to get
closer to the area of ​​political
decision-makers if you
look at the development of world
health with the world health summit
here in Berlin, then that is
exactly the direction you are
doing here with Berlin  science weighs, I
've been following that right from the start
, they have an orientation towards three
different target groups, one
is the general
public interested in science, that's
science communication, the second
is the internal scientific
exchange that
people fly over from San Francisco and the third
is the effect of the  Impact in
politics,
i.e. political advice, so to speak, um how are
you doing it now in this round
2022 which groups uh do you have
in mind in terms of size and how
do you use them and again
I forgot the opening question, how
many participants do you expect this year
in  V  But compared to the previous year
, what is important to me is this orientation in terms of content,
this this must take, here
at
Ronsheimer, this motto is clearly
in the foreground breakthrough thinking, which means whoever gets
something to say
comes on stage with us
, has to say something
[music]
what has to do with the topic of science, also at the
forefront of science
and everything I derive from it yes
we yes I think
everyone who can do something as part of the Bellen
science-weg also has the right to
formulate it differently, we have it that way
some elements that are reminiscent of these
ted conferences but with
us today there is a difference we don't put any
celebrities on stage
who now tell their story of life
why they became a well-known movie star or
rapper or
writer that is with us  not the
case, we put those on the
stage who report about it  What new things have happened in
science and research
over the past 12 to 15
months
and what possible implications does that have,
socially,
economically and politically,
so I believe the idea of ​​this balance sheet
science week is really
networking, drawing attention to
new developments and  the initiation of
discussions on how to deal with this in the future
it is not
primarily aimed at politicians let's say
politicians are, so to speak, one
participant among several I think what
distinguishes us is more the holistic
approach we just have representatives of the
scientists we have  Representatives from
the field of
entrepreneurship because value creation
from research is very important for us too,
the money that research spends, so to speak,
must also be earned somewhere
from there this topic value creation
from research plays a role, we not
only have top
scientists there, but also the
n  next generation we are talking about new communication formats,
so it
really is a holistic approach
that I think is also reflected very
clearly in these very
different formats of the Bülent
science week,
across all disciplines that is
also a unique selling point for us
it's not just business like in Davos it
's not just biomedicine and health
like at World heads with it but it
's really science in its fullest
breadth and beauty yes and also
relevance
so it will probably be spread over the
three days I'll say
111200 but hopefully
we will  we will have to see
so I would like to
ask Christine Brummer again now
we have a different division this
year we also mentioned linnek this year we have three times as many face-to-face
events than
last year and that is of course a
testament to that that we hope  that we have
many present  nz events can also be
implemented this year
Christine if you now have the lines
from last year, so
I think it’s difficult
to compare online and presence again because we
have a lot more presence events this
year, so very briefly a
comparison year is maybe 2019 where
we were able to inspire over 25,000 people to take part in events in the ten
days
we
now have the two years of the pandemic behind us
2020 was completely digital in 2021 there
was a small proportion again
we had around 7000 people in attendance but
in many cases in 2021
there were few
face-to-face events  and for that
we have reached over 65,000 people
worldwide in these ten days this
year it will be a mixture we
have about 70 percent physical formats
assume that we will therefore already
be on the same scale as in
2019 in terms of physical presence
and have  but at the same time by
about 30 Pro  Cent
hybrid or fully digital
events also offer the chance to
continue to reach people worldwide
and in this duality
we believe that designsweg has simply
learned and gained through the two pandemic years, namely
on the one hand physical the stock
that we want to further consolidate and
develop and but of course also  the
digital audience is worldwide which is
also part of the science way and the ten
day festival
they will not use the term world
science together
but
from the word conference is before
the word science
term and we hope it will be a
word science summit we are  well
on the way but the official
name is vorning walls science
summit exactly and balance science week
exactly more questions from the audience
maybe also from the online audience
i look in the direction of my
colleagues
those heranzheimer has
the opportunity again
then i would have a question about zurich
the ETH  As far as I can remember
, ETH
Zurich has been there several times now. ETH Zurich has been there several times at the Berlin
Science Week.
Can you say what kind of effects, what effects,
what use it was for the
Swiss, of course,
you have to ask the ETH questions
,
I'm the city  Zurich no, but I
think the effect is the same
as for the University of Zurich, for
example, or for the other
universities, so international exchange is very important
and you
all know that the
starting point in Switzerland is perhaps a bit special at the
moment compared to Europe and  just
such a platform next to now the
berlins one how is a very important
for the universities so that they can maintain their
cooperation with him partner universities
with whom they sometimes do these events together
I think they have
gained importance in
the last few years
years in the last three years
though  very concrete effects that go beyond
the exchange of female students or the
research area working together
or something like that, i.e. monetary
effects, for example, there
I can give you an answer like he did ETH
Thank you very much Ms. Schindler
any more questions heranzheimer
we still have time
I have one more question  to this
previous senator,
Mr. Müller has now
downgraded the political orientation a bit,
I think you sell yourself
undervalue in a location like Berlin, the
capital
of Germany and also from the
point of view of necessity, it was then
constantly mentioned how important it was  Contributions
of science is to the development of
our country and our society
Question to you as a politician, how do you
look at this
scientific area and what it has to
offer you as a politician when I look at
this crisis scenario
that we are in we are now having an
absolutely crazy discussion in the
le  In the last few weeks about the
further development of nuclear power,
there was no
statement from the scientific community that
actually this and that is such and such and in
terms of energy that and that,
but the politicians raged on
as they wanted and also in the
other things
now gas price caps and so on
are you satisfied with the offer
that science enters your political
space or would you like
scientific political advice,
be it in Berlin now, but you
also have a horizon beyond the
city in
general, what would you like  what should
come from politics from science in
order to become useful that's
more of a yes thank you very much for the question of
course I'm basically never
satisfied as a science senator it
can always be more no but
I have to say I find it
That's a point but I
have to say that I've been there for many
years  As I can already observe
when I started my studies, it
was a big issue for us, especially in
the environmental sciences, that the
scientists do not
express themselves publicly and also not
politically in the sense
that their statements can also be classified,
but always express them  we are
science that has changed completely in 30 years
and I take that very, very
positively and I think that
the Berlin area is a great place
for
everyone who is politically but also
socially active and has a
lot of offers and me  For me
, the Science Weg is on a very
special level here, we have a
lot of offers, every university, every
institution has its own
offers for its own target groups, we also
have the Long Night of
Science, which has a completely different
approach, but it just stops here  with
this claim to also offer an international
stage  en and
exchange in this complexity, which we find
almost only in Europe, almost only
in Berlin, even with this
density of research institutions, that
is an
incredible treasure for me as a
politician and I think for everyone who is involved
in politics in Germany  and
I shouldn't underestimate that, even
if the events are
not specifically aimed at
me as a senator, for example, or at the Senate
or at the Federal Ministry, there are
many people at these conferences from the
political sphere who are in
political consulting  Institutions in
ministries in authorities as
consultants or in foundations
work there for them this is
exactly the exchange space at a high
scientific level what we
need and maybe lastly
I would like to contradict you a bit
I have heard the voices in the current
dispute about nuclear power  also
about energy policy a  They have
n't drunk through yet they
haven't been heard yet I'm not saying they
aren't loud enough but
I think from the political side
we do
n't just have a duty to deliver as one
might think here  but of course we
also have a hollow debt as a
political space and that has not yet been
practiced. The interaction between
politics and science could
actually get even better. The
prerequisites for this, however, are great
and great and they will also be enhanced
by something like the design path
reinforced and better every year,
thank you, Mrs. Senator, we
have one more question and then another one
my name is Gabriel Mittag I head
the press office of an international
organization means Foundation we are taking
part in the Berlin Science Weg for the first time
our topic is we are researching
psychedelica  and the therapeutic
potential in mental illness
My question is to
what extent
new
research projects or a new one have
emerged as a result of the Berlin science week, also within the
research institutions, or is it,
so to
speak, then the exchange in
contact is limited to these ten days? It could
also be the birth of new
global and international
research projects
can I try an answer
that is
at least not the claim of the
balance science way there are many
events where afterwards
theses papers are created where so-called
white-papers are produced which then
sooner or later quietly and
some drawers
disappear our offer to those
who  come here is come listen
to what the various
actors have to say in
all this variety and maybe take it with you
as food for thought for your
own work
and to be honest that is also very
appreciated, especially in politics
so Ms. Gothe is very strong and other
politicians in
broadcast mode that's just the way she
oaths from one event to the
other I've heard from various people
, especially from
politicians, how beneficial it is just to spend
a few hours  Walking around every day and
listening without
expecting good action
or
strong action, just
walking around listening to being inspired,
taking the time to think
and then maybe developing something
new out of it, and
we
haven’t been systematically pursuing that yet, but we are  I keep
hearing that through contacts that are also made
in the coffee queue, we
have many interesting people who
are guests with us, that I can
then
develop activities or initiatives from them bilaterally or multilaterally,
but
we can't have a list,
yes, it's magical.
I just wanted to say this concept of
breakthroughs that is  t one thing, of course,
for an academy that always
elects members and when electing members
makes sure that they have interesting
breakthroughs not that we
somehow always sit there and have a piece of paper
and write them down I mean but,
so to speak, there is a relationship
between the concept of  Breakthroughs and
a central category of the
election of members of the
Berlin-Brandenburg Academy of
Sciences, so to that
extent it also plays a
role for the city and then I wanted to say
again about the conversation between Ms.
Gohde and Mr. Ronsheimer,
we are now in contact with the
Science Council  Format as BBAW is
considering how to have the
prepaidness of scientific
political advice in the area of
crises, i.e. the crisis has the problem that is
not foreseeable,
at least to a large extent, but how you
can increase it and are in the process of developing a
format, there are often
hearts closed at the moment  much advice 150
Pa  piere on the same topics that
we communicate with each other how
things are concentrated the Leopoldina the
science council the DFG the BBAW and
that is in preparation so the lessons
learned from the
current multiple crisis that is
already being taken very seriously that
now there is no specific topic because of the
breakthrough  It is not yet ready for
us to present this as a breakthrough
, but one could well imagine for the
next year that one
could present not only the scientific
breakthrough but also an attempt at
a breakthrough from the breakthroughs
in other regions,
so this is a cautious one, so to speak
Outlook
[music]
jokingly renamed to falling walls
and some new regulations,
so that's
a complex question that you
addressed there, which basically goes
a bit in the
direction of what herontzheimer
addressed and what he likes  shoot
open  ffen has
how do we deal with
future scenarios, so to
speak, also against the background of crises
that cannot be foreseen
that also has something to do with this topic of think
tanks in
modern German, which are sometimes more,
how should I put it, finger exercises
and not so much scripts scripts
Playbox  for the future or for the
future also
deliver on futures that may
be based
on rather improbable or
perhaps also taboo
events that is missing
that also has to do with the topic of foresight
and what is then of
interest to politics is of course in the
context there we are  Then
again on the topic of breakthroughs, how
do I deal with the
basic conditions, i.e. the political
framework conditions, but also the
whole regulation, in order to
perhaps consciously enable certain things or
consciously include them
. Of course, everything is also
addressed in the many topics that
are part of the Berlin Science Week
be treated  but that's
not the main topic right now, but I
think you can't
separate them in the end and I think especially those from
politics and business, also from
science, the questions, of course, even
if something new happens,
just take christbas or
[music].
Topics that then come up again, such
as the topic of nuclear energy, what does it actually mean,
how should we
deal with it socially
, I think it is also good to make it an issue early enough
in terms of preparing
society for the difficult
discussion that will then take place and you have to take positions,
please, sir  marxis so I
think
falling walls in the sense of breakthroughs
would be misunderstood by the organizers
if only it would be higher faster
I think you can always see the Mainz
development of the vaccine in
addition to the admiration you have for it
I always ask myself why
is that  there happened and and why
what does that have to do with Gru  To do research on the final situation,
so I think it's automatically part of it,
at least when we're discussing here
, we
're getting involved more and more like
Humboldt University, and one of the
basic considerations was that it's always
a good opportunity for me to do that earlier
with Ukraine
Julia von Blumenthal demonstrated it again
very clearly with this wonderful
formulation since February 24th 20th,
nobody can overlook what one
could have seen before at many points
, so I always look
back and why not look
earlier  why so and so
our academy members would be
I think very angry if this part wasn't
there
So, so to speak,
the circumstances that made
Mainz  he team managed to do it so
wonderfully quickly and that it came out of
basic research,
so I always think that's one of the
really exciting things there, so I
think that could also be a suggestion for
a panel at the next Berlin
Science Week, so taking notes  we
fall now and plan for that in the
next eleven months if the wonderful
red cube resists here
we have another comment from
julia von blumenthal
you have seen the falling walls now in
relation to a certain way of
thinking i would have it even stronger
on one  Seen at the meta level, that
is precisely the question of
thinking where the wall falling in thinking
is precisely ecological
questions that become relevant
and visible when you also think into the system what
you previously externalized in the
economy
and when you  the example of Ukraine
seeing a Russian war of aggression against Ukraine was there  the problem
of limiting one's perspective if
the view mostly only extends to the
outer border of the European
Union then one does not see what is
behind it with the full
clarity with which one should see and
these are now the
short-sightednesses of which we already
know and  It is always important to me
that the task for scientists is to discover
the short-sightedness that we still
have that we are not aware of right
now and
that is exactly falling walls
walls bring down
narrowing open up and then
actually
to look at tomorrow's question
thank you very much thank you I think unfortunately we do
n't have time
no time okay thank you very much
again for everyone involved thank you very much for being
with us and yes we will see
you at the Berlin science-2022
thank you again
[Applause]